[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt's leckere plätzchen und zwar
mache ich mutter kugel
den namen habe ich mir zu locker kugel
nenne ich sie und zwar sind es kleine
plätzchen die sind und deswegen gucken
und in der mitte haben sie einen richtig
leckeren tapas schokoladen cam die sind
auch super einfach hergestellt ist ein
sehr einfacher teig und ich habe im teig
ein bisschen espresso mit drin
wer natürlich keine nespresso markt
durch den weg und kann ihn auch
austauschen
mit milch zum beispiel also durch milch
oder durch likör oder was anderes aber
ich finde so wie sie jetzt im sinn sie
wirklich sehr perfekt vor allem im
stadtteil ohne eine wirklich sehr müde
und total lecker zerfällt im mund und
dieser show kern der stadt noch mal
schön knackig und hebt den ganzen
geschmack noch mal richtig hervor ich
zeige euch jetzt da vorne mal die
zutaten für den mürbeteig an zutaten
brauche ich 150 gramm stärke 60 gramm
mehl einen halben teelöffel zimt 30
gramm kakaopulver 50 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt 130 gramm kalte
butter und zwei esslöffel espresso wenn
natürlich der wichtel in bisher gibt
jetzt nämlich zuerst einmal die
trockenen zutaten und das heißt mädel
stärke kaka und puderzucker und
vermische die jetzt in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt das ganze
natürlich auch mit den händen verkneten
oder in einem mixer zum beispiel und bei
diesem teil ist jetzt ganz besonders
dass ich mehr stärker an teilhabe als
mehl und dadurch werden die plätzchen
einfach so richtig mürbe und richtig
fein
ich kenne das auch von türkischem gebäck
also von kohlrabi und das wird richtig
lecker war dass wir müssen jetzt mal
kurz
da gebe ich jetzt an dem der extrakt mit
rein und der rest ist er in der flasche
ist den kriegt er am besten raus wenn
ihr da einfach ein bisschen in mich rein
gibt schüttelt und daneben weiter
verwendet das ist nämlich im westen bei
meinem nächsten rührteig oder beim
kaffee schmeckt sehr gut kommt die kalte
butter rhein in kleinen stückchen und
auch zwei essen dafür lässt
und die zutaten werden nicht gut
miteinander verknetet
[Musik]
nämlich den teig und auf die
arbeitsfläche das jetzt noch nicht aus
aber ich werde jetzt gleich mit den
händen verbinden und da wird die mutter
einfach ein bisschen warm und steigt
gibt es auch gleich ganz gut
[Musik]
den teig werde ich jetzt gleich abdecken
und für etwa 15 minuten im kühlschrank
ruhen lassen und dann wieder gleich
weiter verarbeitet
der teig ist jetzt etwas ausgeruht das
klingt erstmal noch mal kurz durch der
hälfte
dann eine rolle
und wenn die so ungefähr 30 ist kommen
jetzt immer gleichmäßig große stücke lag
und die werden jetzt jeweils zu einer
kugel geformt und dann auf ein blech
gesetzt
ich habe jetzt etwa 50 kugeln
herausbekommen jetzt nehmt ihr eine
kugel in die hand und stellt jetzt mit
dem kleinen finger oder zum beispiel mit
einem whirlpool oder einem anderen
gegenstand so eine ganz kleine mulde ein
ganz vorsichtig auch nicht zu tief die
kugel reißt so ein bisschen ein aber
gerade das finde ich richtig schön und
natürlich später nach dem backen nämlich
die zar peter kubatur 1
[Musik]
die kekse werden jetzt bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze im kabinett zum backofen für
etwa zwölf minuten gefallen die kekse
sind jetzt abgekühlt die sind schon
gebacken und hier habe ich jetzt 100
gramm peter kuvertüre bereits temperiert
das heißt zwei drittel davon über einem
heißen wasserbad erwärmt und geschmolzen
und dann das restliche drittel einfach
dazugehört und diese kuvertüre werde ich
jetzt hier reingehen in einen
spritzbeutel ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel einfach einen gefrierbeutel
nehmen und bevor ich die kuvertüre jetzt
in dieser mulde rein gieße werde ich die
kekse mit süßem schnäbel streuen
es geht noch mal einen schönen kontrast
und sieht einfach weihnachtlich aus
dieser schnee schmilzt nicht auf der
oberfläche zeigen nämlich den immer ganz
gerne stadt puderzucker die zeichen ganz
kleines loch rein also die ganz gleich
wie spitze ab und befülle jetzt di
modena mit
[Musik]
die kuvertüre sitzt fest und mir
gefallen sie optisch sehr gut und ich
habe es auch schon passiert
superlecker mama und erwitte habe ich
auch probieren wir unser mira darf auch
gespannt weil ich die ganze familie
probieren sie die trophäe eigentlich
irgendwie nur irgendwie so ein bisschen
erinnert mich auch daran ja zu diesen
tollen mögen teilt uns dann die knackige
lecker es ist ein bisschen ist
resultieren aber ein keks dafür lassen
das passt also ich finde das schmeckt
den mob also den espresso gut raus aber
nicht so stark dass er stört also ich
finde richtiger ideal mit dem kakao
wir schauen was fahrgemeinschaft neuen
freund beim erhält wirklich klasse
bisher stehen wir alle und essen als die
walker kekse ja und falls ihr euch jetzt
auch für das rezept interessiert dann
geht auf 6 - blog.de da stets noch mal
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachhaken und bis zum nächsten mal
das passte zum tee auf jedenfalls selbst
und ist es nokia ist hat jetzt seine
fallen so schön wär ich finds ja auch
roten teppich der mannschaft war fehler
nochmals nein noch nicht gleich gebaut
[Musik]